Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. When you get into an Escape Plug-in Hybrid, you get the perfect mix. You can chill in electric mode, You get the perfect mix. You can chill in electric mode, turn it up in gas mode, or get the best of both in hybrid mode. Choose how you move in the all-in-one Escape.
And right now, get 0% APR purchase financing for up to 60 months on the 2025 Escape plug-in hybrid. For details, visit your Toronto Area Ford store or ford.ca. Strange tales were told of Olaf Trigvasson's return to Norway. One day it was claimed the new king was in a fit mood to be entertained. At his side there suddenly appeared an old man, cloaked and white-haired, with only a single eye. Entering into conversation with the stranger, Trigvasson found that there was nothing the old man did not seem to know, nor any question to which he could not give an answer.
All evening the two of them talked, and even though the King was eventually persuaded to retire to bed by a twitchy English bishop who had grown suspicious of the one-eyed stranger, Trigverson could still not bear to end the conversation but continued it even as he lay on his furs late into the night. At last the old man left him, and the king fell asleep. But his dreams were strange and feverish, and waking up abruptly he cried out for the stranger again.
Even though his servants searched high and low, however, the old man could not be found, and Trigverson, brought to his senses by daylight, shuddered at his close escape. When it was reported to him that two sides of beef, a gift from the stranger, had been used in a stew, he ordered the entire cooking pot flung out. A godly and responsible act, for clearly it was out of the question for him as a follower of Christ to feast on meat supplied by Odin. Well that riveting passage finally wrought prose that was produced by none other than
our very own Hollywood's own Tom Holland in his book Millennium It's about the end of the world and the forging of Christendom. Is that what the subtitle of the book? Yeah, that kind of stuff exactly I thought a nice compliment to the reading from your own book on this subject with which we ended the previous episode So a nice segue there a perfect match We ended last time with a reading from Fury of the Vikings. Listeners may remember that Danish refugees in the wake of a terrible massacre in the towns and villages of England have fled across the North Sea to Scandinavia to bring the news to the Danish King and revenge is coming. So today in this mighty series about the events of 1066, we
turn from England to Scandinavia, to the Northlands. We look north to the world of the Vikings, which is now beginning to change. And that opening reading about Olaf Trigvason rejecting Odin's beef is a reminder of the throes of cultural and social change that are transforming Scandinavia. So Tom, you talked last time about this guy Olaf Trigverson. He is a terrifying, slightly sinister Viking leader who had beaten an English army in 991 at the Battle of Malden, who had led all these pillaging raids across southern England and has extorted a huge amount of silver from England's King Æthelred the Unready. But Olaf Trigversen is an embodiment of change in himself, isn't he?
Because he's converted to Christianity and he's been paid off by Ethelred and he has gone back to Norway. So tell us a little bit about him and why he matters. Yeah. So he's returned to Norway, the North way, the great road that kind of winds up the coast of Norway. And he is setting about transforming himself from a pagan Viking chieftain into the intimidating figure of a Christian king.
And he does this with the same buccaneering enthusiasm that he had shown in extorting cash from the English. So he goes up and down the North way and he smashes idols and he menaces local pagan leaders and he forces conversions of his countrymen at the point of a sword and he throws out Odin's beef. And I think as that story suggests, his conversion is up to a point pretty genuine. But the question then is why, why would he having imposed himself so formidable on our Christian kingdom, why would he then convert to the God of the seeming losers? And I think the answer is that everything he does is very finely calculated to make him look good, to kind of redound to his glory, to add to his potency and power.
And the truth is that even though he had extorted money from the English, he can do that because England is rich. And I think he has seen enough of, you know, this great Christian kingdom ruled by Athelred to think, well, I would quite like a bit of what Athelred has. Yeah. You know, he may, we may think of him as a loser, but Athelred is heir to Alfred the great.
He's a figure of dignity, of splendor, of wealth, and Olaf wants it. To worship Odin is basically to be parochial, to be poor, to be someone who has to be a predator and to worship Christ is to be powerful and rich and possessed of enough silver if you have to, to kind of give it out. Yeah, I think it's important for people to get that into their heads, isn't it? The Christianization of Scandinavia is the moment that really marks the end of the Viking Age. But it's not because these warlords think kindness is brilliant and I love turning the
other cheek and all that kind of thing. It's because they think Christianity is a winner's religion. People who are Christians are rich, they're powerful. And also if you're a king, you know, to have one religion, one God, that sounds great. You know, get everyone to believe the same thing and therefore believe in you. And I think it's more than just about belief. God. That sounds great. You know, get everyone to believe the same thing and therefore believe in you. And I think it's more than just about belief. It's also about the apparatus of power that Christianity provides because it's very much a literate civilization. You have bishops
who can serve you as ministers that could then enable you to kind of construct the kind of kingdom that you find in England. It enables you to have more sophisticated ways, essentially of raising troops. And therefore the offer is that you can be even more bloodthirsty and extort even more money. Ultimately is the kind of the base practical reason for it. And the degree to which this is something that is very much in the air in the early 11th century is the fact that Olaf Trigvasson is not the first Viking
warlord to have clocked this. So south of the North Way you go across these icy reef strewn waters that separate Norway from Denmark and there you come to the flatlands of Jutland and there stands the seat of the kings of Denmark. And we talked in the first episode about how England is very precocious but it's not entirely unique because in Denmark at the same time as the Kyrgyz, the great dynasty of Alfred the Great, are establishing their rule over a United Kingdom of England, a dynasty of kings in Denmark are doing much the same thing. And they set up a great kind of showcase
of their dynasty's power at a place called Yelling, which is in the heart of Jutland. And it is, you know, we've already alluded to Tolkien. It is like something out of Lord of the Rings. It's a place of ancient graves and you've got gold ringed warriors with their swords and their spears standing on guard outside kind of great halls, great feasting halls. And you also have two huge mounds of earth that had been raised by Gorm.
It's a great name. Gorm the Old. Gorm the Old, who is the founder of this dynasty and had been a pagan. But the amazing thing is, is that between these two great barrows, these two great pagan piles of earth, there stands a church. And beside the church, there is a great block of granite that has been carved into the stone with an image of a crucified Christ who is entangled with serpents and it's inscribed with runes. And these runes read, and I quote, King Harold had this memorial made for Gorm, his father,
and Fiery, his mother, that same Harold who joined together all Denmark and Norway and made the Danes to be Christian. Yeah, it's an amazing site actually. I'll tell you what, it's accessible within half a day from Legoland. I know, I remember it well. It's an excellent trip. The Danish Tourist Board, if they want to sponsor us, they really ought to because I recommend it to the listeners as a long weekend. You can knock off Legoland and the Yelling Stones in the same trip. And of course this matters because these stones, the inspiration, the guy who set them up King Harold, you mentioned his, his nickname is Bluetooth and these stones showing the
integration of, of pagan and Christian. And of course, um, all Denmark and Norway being joined together are the inspiration for Bluetooth technology. Would you believe? Yes. And the symbol for Bluetooth as kind of fusion of the runes for H and B. So that the two initials of Harold Bluetooth. Yeah.
And the idea behind naming that technology Bluetooth was this idea that Harold had joined together Denmark and Norway. In fact, it was just the southern reaches of Norway. Like this is teaching all the world to sing Kumbaya. Wonderful. Of course, I mean, there was nothing touchy feely about it at all. It was a very brutal process of conquest. And you can see in this kind of great rock, this great stone with the symbol of Christ carved on it, that the process of conquest is being elided with the process of becoming Christian. And as you said, to be the servant of a kind of single omnipotent God rather than a whole host of gods, this is to be a Caesar.
This is potentially to have power that is far more prestigious than anything that the pagan world could offer. And of course, as we said, also it brings bureaucracy and bureaucracy in turn enables the organization of a treasury and a treasury enables the commissioning of infrastructure and the building of ships and the arming of ever larger armies. And the Danish king who best demonstrates this is not Harold himself, but his son, Svein Forkbeard, who at the end of the last episode, you reminded us, had cold blue eyes.
In his cold blue eyes, Tom, there was only death. Because Svein Forkbeard has just heard the news of the massacre of Danes in England. And he has also, according to some sources, heard that one of the victims is his own sister, Gunnhilde. Right. And this is a man with whom you do not want to mess. So Tietmar, the Bishop of Merseburg, said that he was, and I quote, not a ruler, but a destroyer.
And Sveinforthbeard, he may be a new kind of Dane in that he is a king in a Christianizing world, and he has more bureaucracy behind him and all of this kind of thing. So he's not a Viking Raider or a Viking Warlord, but he's just as frightening and formidable as the most sinister and blood drenched of Alfred the Great's adversaries or whatever. Yeah, I think he's a much more frightening figure, much more kind of chill and calculating than any of the pagan Vikings actually.
And either the boneless. Yes, precisely because he is starting to kind of institutionalize his menace, but you still have the slight vein of brutal comedy that you often get in Viking epics. So the story of how he comes to power, he actually topples his father, Harold Bluetooth. So in 986, he leads a rebellion against Harold and there are various stories that are told of Harold's ends and The most comical and therefore the one that we will go with Do you tell in your book not necessarily the truest but the one that you you enjoyed the most on I think it's right So yeah, so the father and son have a kind of parley on an island
They're just about you know They've got all their fleets behind them and then Harold Bluetooth goes off to go to the toilet to have a kind of parley on an island. They're just about, you know, they've got all their fleets behind them. And then Harold Bluetooth goes off to go to the toilet to have a dump. And as he sits down to start the process, an arrow is fired and it goes straight up his anus. And this will not be the last toilet themed death that we will be touching on in the course of this series. So Svein had been a comrade of Olaf Trigvason, the guy who rejected Odin's beef, but they are rivals within the world of the North Sea, aren't they?
One of them is Norway, the other is Denmark, basically. Yes. And Svein had fought with Olaf Trigvason at Malden, so was fully aware of his potential and his formidable qualities. And so therefore decides that he's going to have to eliminate him. And one of the many ways I think in which Sveinfortbeard is a frightening figure is that he's a great man for delayed gratification. So he takes his time and he slowly builds up an ever more intimidating force with which to take on the Norwegian king.
And in the year 1000, this great fleet set sail to destroy Olof Trigvison. Trigvison himself is kind of ready for it. He's got an absolutely enormous kind of dragon ship called the Long Serpent, the largest dragon ship ever fashioned. He's got 60 ships that are kind of similarly impressive and intimidating. So these two great armadas sailing out to meet one another, but Falkbeard's force is ultimately far more intimidating. Olaf Triggvissen's fleet is rapidly wiped out and ends with Triggvissen himself, who
has got golden armor, bright red cloak, so kind of very on brand. His enemies have cornered him, they're about to grab him and Olof Trygvason leaps into the sea and when Sveinfoltbeard's men tried to rescue him from the waters, he threw his shield over his head, it is said, and vanished beneath the waves. And so he dies as he had lived as a great Viking hero, a man whose name will be celebrated in song. But Swain Forkbeard has secured for himself power beyond the dreams of any previous Scandinavian king.
Right. So this is I think Swain Forkbeard at this point, who is this very formidable character, of course famous for his beard. We should stress this. He has this forked beard, which I think in itself is quite intimidating. Yeah. So he is the man that Ethel read the unready has basically chosen to provoke. It's mad, but I guess I thought he had no choice.
He just, he thought the Danes were a fifth column and he just had to get rid. But I mean, you've said in your notes that if he'd been facing somebody else, it might've been a reasonable calculation, but as it is, because word is bound to reach Svein Fortbeard, it's, and I quote, the worst policy decision in the whole of English history. I mean, Bridget Phillipson might have something to say about that, Tom. I say there's a case for saying. Yeah, it's in the top two.
I think it's a moral disaster, obviously, because actually murdering people who are your guests in your kingdom is a terrible look, no matter whether you have kind of apocalyptic justifications or not. But I think it's an insane misreading of not just Feind Falkbeard himself, but the capabilities of the Danish kingdom. And I guess the reason that Ethelred misreads it is that he is thinking that Denmark is still the country that it was back in the pagan days. He hasn't clocked the fact that it is starting to become a kingdom very much like his own.
And the consequences are utterly disastrous and I think that anyone in England listening to this who is currently depressed about the state of the country should sit back and reflect on the fact that it was actually a lot worse in the latter years of Ethel Redd's reign. So let's get into Svein Forkbeard's revenge. So he clearly spends the next few months mustering his forces, assembling his fleet, sharpening their swords. And then a few months after the St. Bryce's Day massacre in 1003, he lands in Wessex in the heartland of the English kingdom at the head of this gigantic fleet and
a massive expeditionary force and Tom he wants to bleeding and dry as so many raiders have done but also he's after Ethel Redd's authority the symbols of his authority and he heads for where else for Wiltshire and the Salisbury area. It does. Yeah, he does. So he first of all lands in Devon, but he storms and burns Exeter. And then he marches on my own native county of Wiltshire
and it's county town of Wilton. And Wilton is one of the great symbols of the authority of the Curda Kingz, the dynasty of Alfred the Great, and particularly of its women. So Wilton is the site of an abbey that lies under the particular protection of the royal women of the royal dynasty. And so to attack it in a way is to insult Atharad's masculinity, his inability to defend the property of his women.
And it has a kind of great spiritual potency. So two sisters of Athelstan, the first King of United England had been nuns there. Um, and in nine 55, this is very interesting for me. One of the brothers of Athelstan who had ruled in succession to him as King had granted to the nuns of Wilton, two villages in the nearby chalk Valley. One of them was a village called Bower Chalk and the other was a village called Broad Chalk and that's where I grew up. So this is very much my neck of the woods.
Yeah. And it means that I have a particular devotion to the memory of this great Abbey. Uh, and one of the great saints of the Kerdeg Kengas had also been there. So this is Edgar's daughter Edith and therefore the half sister of Athelred. She'd been very devout, very holy, much loved by the locals for her kind of kindness and generosity, but she'd also been celebrated for her tremendous dress sense. By far the most stylishly dressed nun in England and she had been criticized for this, but God demonstrated his approval of her kind of sassy dress sense by making a burning torch drop into the great chest where she kept her
clothes and the chest got kind of, you know, blackened, but her clothes completely survived. So it was a spectacular miracle. Yeah, that must have definitely happened. Well, you may scoff Dominic, but when she dies, she's only kind of in her late twenties. The memory of this extraordinary miracle is such that she is enshrined as a saint. Golly, well. So what do you say? What do you make of that?
I think it's bonkers, but I mean, God, honestly, mercy and mercy and skepticism. I have no time for Wessex as saints, to be honest with you. I just I look down on them. Well, I think that reflects poorly on you. And maybe you would have been at one with Svein. I would. I would have thrown my lot in with Svein straight away. Svein is marching on Wilton.
He's marching on Wiltshire and the Salisbury area at the head of a marauding, hairy band of Vikings. And of course it's the duty of the elder man of Wiltshire, a guy called Alfrick, to stop them, to preserve this great symbol of West Saxon royal power. And he arrives on the crest of the hill, looking down at Wilton, he sees the Viking horde. All his men are lined up waiting for him to sound the battle Trump. Yeah. And instead he's so terrified that he voids his bow and vomits all over the soil. That is the, that's what I associate with people from that neck of the woods, Tom.
That's the behavior that I've come to recognize. He runs away and Svein torches Wilton, Lutzi Abbe of its gold. And of course, you know, this is devastating to Ather Red in every way. Right. He's lost the money and he's been humiliated. This great symbol of his power has been devastated and Svein makes sure to extort everything that he can and ultimately you know he only leaves in 10.04 after Ethelred has given him yet more Dane Geld. So now we really are into
the routine of Dane Geld aren't we because the issue now is that Svein knows he can just come back again and again, hit England, get more Dane Geld and use that Dane Geld. I mean this is your Kipling lines, you know, if you pay Dane Geld you will never get rid of the Dane because Svein uses that to beef up his army, beef up his fleet and then come back the next year or two years later for more money. Yeah, it's like going to a cash point with somebody else's card. Right because every time the Danes return 10 06 10 09 they are better equipped more
formidable more terrifying. I have to say there's an absolutely brilliant book on this that I read a few years ago by a Norwegian historian called Tore Skaer called the Wolf Age and it does this in basically kind of week by week narrative. And it just goes on and on and on. Of all of these conquests. And they're one of the key characters is a guy called Thorkell the Tall. And he is very tall.
But he's called Thorkell. Yeah. We've established that. So he's really brutal and effective, isn't he? I mean, he keeps looting and pillaging all these towns. And so in 1011, they go for a place that's even more significant than Wilshire in the Salisbury area, which is Canterbury. Yeah, their seat of Christianity in England.
And they capture the archbishop. They lock him up in a cage and they keep him there for six months. And then they hold a great celebratory feast at Greenwich, kind of downriver from London at Easter. Yeah, on Easter Saturday. Yeah. And they get absolutely wasted and they've been eating mighty haunches of beef. And there are great skulls of oxen and bones and stuff. And they all start pelting the archbishop
with these bones and the poor guy dies. Do you know the name of the man who this is so Tolkien, the name of the man who finished the archbishop off he was called thrum. Yeah, Thorkell and thrum. Yeah. And this is again to emphasize just abject humiliation for Atheraed. I mean it's bad enough to see the great Abbey patronized by the women of your dynasty wiped out but to have the archbishop of your kingdom pelted
to death with ox bones, I mean, it doesn't get worse than that really. So in the long run, Ethelred's solution is yet again, financial. He can't fight England. It's interesting, isn't it? That England, despite being so wealthy, just doesn't have the martial tradition, the martial culture. It does. It does. And this is where I think the revisionism on Ethere gets it wrong.
Okay. He has shown that he can fight. I mean, he invaded Scotland. He launched an attack on Normandy. Spoiler alert, his eldest son will show that it's perfectly possible to raise troops and to fight. So why doesn't he do it in a convincing and effective way? I suspect that the humiliations heaped on him has broken his prestige and the resentment of him as a man who just keeps extorting money and handing it over.
Yeah. Is kind of corroding the willingness of people to kind of go the extra length for him. People basically think he's a loser and they don't want to back him up. People do think he's a loser and where I think think he's a loser. And where I think it is, it is reasonable to say that a threat is unlucky is just to emphasize the fact that he is up against something new with this. The fact that Denmark is a state rather than a kind of consortium of Raiders. I think this is something that he hasn't properly clocked, but he really should have done by this point.
He should have fought. And in 1012, I think Ethered decides the policy's not working. What I need to do is to try and specifically buy off some of these raiders and employ them as my mercenaries. And he targets Thorkell the Tall, this guy who had captured the Archbishop of Canterbury, gives him another massive bribe and wins Thorkell over together with 45 ships. Um, but the problem is that this policy, which may be 10 or 20 years before would have worked is a failure because it just makes Svein alarmed.
You know, he doesn't want to think of Athelred teaming up with someone as formidable as Thorkell. And so he decides the time has come for me to invade. And as he had done with Olaf Trigvasson, with Aethelred, he's been playing a very long game and his policy with Aethelred has been to bleed him dry of the lifeblood of silver and then to close in for decapitation. And so in 1013, that is what he does. He sails up the Humber Estuary with a huge invasion force and the Humber estuary effectively,
if you're facing Vikings from across the North sea, is like a dagger point sticking into the heart of England because it leads to York, the great second city of England and which for so long had been a Viking capital. There's loads of Danes in this area. I mean, there are people with Danish surnames. There are Danish place names. Yeah. There are all these people who perhaps for whom it is perhaps not such a stretch
to imagine having a Danish overlord rather than an English one. And it seems pretty clear at this point, doesn't it? Do you agree that Svein he's this isn't another raid. He's like, right, let's finish this now. I'm actually just going to take this over and this is going to become part of my empire. Yeah. He's been planning it and now the moment has come and he combines menace with overtures to the local aristocracy in Mercia and they are so battle scarred and weary that they start accepting Svein's terms and handing
over hostages, offering homage to Svein. And by the end of that year, 1013, Arthur Redd is effectively staring down the barrel. He no longer has the run of his country. He's bottled himself up with Thorkell in London, but he knows that he can't hold out for long, that the whole country now effectively is submitting to the Danish king. And so he orders his queen, the lady Emma, who is of course the sister of the Duke of Normandy, go on board a ship and to take with her their three children. So there's a two boys, Edward and Alfred and a
girl called Giffo. And once they're on the ship to set sail for Normandy. And this will be really important later on the fact that these children, one of whom is called Edward, so listeners should remember him, are disappearing into exile in Normandy to her homeland. Exactly. Arthur still can't quite bring himself to endure the humiliation of seeking sanctuary with the Duke of Normandy.
So instead he leaves London and he kind of hangs out on the Isle of Wight, spends Christmas there and it's miserable because effectively he is now the Viking. His court has shrunk to his fleet and in the year, he kind of gives up and in the dying days of, of 1013. So in the days immediately after Christmas, he, he decides that this is hopeless and he too set sail for the Norman court. So now the dynasty that has ruled England for so long, the dynasty of Alfred and of Edward the elder and of Athelstan has just, has gone off into exile the Danes are the masters of England and a Danish king
and a Danish king. Yeah in Svein Forkbeard and then an unbelievable George RR Martin style twist the 3rd of February 1014. Tell us what happens to Svein Forkbeard Tom. Well he dies and there are conflicting accounts about what exactly happens to him. So some say that he died in his sleep. Others that he fell off his horse and smashed his head. And others say that he was killed by St Edmund, the King of East Anglia, who back in the time of King Alfred had been shot to death by pagan Vikings and had since been enshrined as the great patron saint of the East Angles.
Let's say Edmund had appeared to Svein Forkbeard in a dream and struck him with a pole and that had finished him off. So listeners, make up your own minds. Was he killed by St Edmund in a dream with a pole or did he, as I read in another book, have a stroke near Scunthorpe? How are you basically you can divide the human race into people who think go with the stroke and Scunthorpe or the pole people. Um, what I will also say is again, over the course of this story, um, people dying unexpectedly and often it's mentioned at feasts again, this is an enduring theme
and people might want to ponder whether perhaps foul play was an operation, but we don't know. Anyway, so the Sveinfort Beat is now off the scene. And so the Witan, this great assembly of the elder men, the men who lead the various counties in England, they get together and they decide, ah, actually, maybe we should get Ethelred back. And the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle gives the details of the invitation they sent to Ethelred.
They said, no sovereign was dearer to them than their natural lord. If only he would govern them better than he had previously done. Which yeah, that's not really an endorsement, is it? But Ethelred does obviously come back. He does. So Thorkell switched sides by this point. Thorkell is now back with the Danes. Yes.
But there's a Norwegian on the scene, a guy called Olaf Haraldson and Dominic will be hearing about him again soon. He's a very stout man. Very stout. Yes. And very saintly in the long run despite being very murderous. So Olaf Haraldson helps capture London for Atharad from the Danes. He sails up the Thames and he pulls down London Bridge.
但有一位挪威人出现在现场，一个叫奥拉夫·哈拉尔森（Olaf Haraldson）的人，多米尼克很快就会再次听到他的消息。他是个非常健壮的男人。非常健壮。是的。尽管杀戮无数，但从长远来看，他非常圣洁。所以奥拉夫·哈拉尔森帮助埃塞尔雷德从丹麦人手中夺回了伦敦。他乘船逆泰晤士河而上，并拉倒了伦敦桥。
I'm never entirely sure how pulling down London Bridge helps him. But he does. And there's a kind of, there is a thesis that this is the origins of the nursery rhyme London Bridge is falling down. The other great champion of the English resistance to the Danes is Ethered's eldest son. So that's not by Emma, but by a previous queen. This is a guy called Edmund. He had scorned to flee England when Ethered and his sons by Emma had gone.
我从不完全确定拉倒伦敦桥对他是怎么个帮法。但他确实这么做了。有一种观点认为，这就是童谣《伦敦桥要塌了》的起源。英国人抵抗丹麦人的另一位伟大英雄是埃塞尔雷德的长子。所以这不是埃玛生的，而是前一位王后生的。这家伙叫埃德蒙（Edmund）。当埃塞尔雷德和他在埃玛所生的儿子们逃走时，他曾对逃离英格兰不屑一顾。
He'd stayed in England. He's very charismatic. He's very brave. And he's so formidable in battle that he wins the nickname of iron side. He's a tremendous man. Isn't he? And actually you could say he is the last English King in the sense that he is the last King to rule who is of purely English descent.
他留在了英格兰。他极具个人魅力。他非常勇敢。他在战斗中极其勇猛，以至于赢得了“勇士”（iron side）的绰号。他是个了不起的人。不是吗？事实上，你可以说他是最后一位英国国王，因为他是最后一位纯英格兰血统的统治者。
When we make this as a TV drama, he should be played by an AI de aged Sean Bean. That will give people a clue as to what happens when he's going to win. In fact, yes, more toilet based deaths are approaching, but for now he's done very well in fact, he's so cross with, with Ethel Red that he's basically kind of binned him and is, is saying, Oh, well I should be king and between them Edmund Ironside and Olaf Haraldson succeed in reestablishing the rule of the Kyrgyz. The prospects for Edmund Ironside as a future
当我们把这拍成电视剧时，他应该由经过AI减龄处理的肖恩·宾（Sean Bean）来扮演。这能给人们一点暗示，让他们知道他获胜时会发生什么。事实上，是的，更多与厕所相关的死亡即将来临，但就目前而言，他干得非常出色，事实上，他对埃塞尔雷德非常恼火，以至于基本上把对方晾在一边，并且说，哦，好吧，我才应该是国王，埃德蒙·伊恩赛德和奥拉夫·哈拉尔森联手成功恢复了库克王朝的统治。埃德蒙·伊恩赛德作为未来
king are all the brighter for the fact that his father by now is a dying man. And in 1016, he duly shuffles off this mortal coil, but his passing actually is barely noted because by now everyone's eyes is on Edmund Ironside. You know, he's tremendous. He's dashing. His sides are made of iron and he claims the throne. Yeah. There is however a problem because he is not the only claimant to this throne.
国王的前景更加光明，因为他的父亲此时已经病入膏盲。公元1016年，他理所当然地走完了这平凡的一生，但他的离去几乎没有引起人们的注意，因为此时所有人的目光都聚焦在埃德蒙·伊恩赛德身上。你知道，他太棒了。他风度翩翩。他的身躯由铁铸就，他宣称继承王位。是的。然而，这里有个问题，因为他不是这个王位的唯一继承人。
There is a rival and who that is and how the contest of this rival with Edmund Ironside develops, we will discover after the break. I'm David Oleshoge, historian and broadcaster. And I'm Sarah Churchwell, author, journalist and academic. And together, we are hosts of Goalhanger's latest podcast, Journey Through Time. We're going to be looking at hidden social histories behind famous chapters from the past. Asking what it was like to have lived through prohibition or to have been there on the ground
还有一个竞争对手，他是谁，以及这位对手与埃德蒙·伊恩赛德的竞争将如何发展，我们将在中场休息后揭晓。我是历史学家兼广播员大卫·奥列绍格（David Oleshoge）。我是作家、记者兼学者莎拉·丘奇韦尔（Sarah Churchwell）。我们联手主持Goalhanger的最新播客《穿越时空》（Journey Through Time）。我们将探讨过去著名篇章背后隐藏的社会历史。探究经历禁酒令是什么感觉，或者亲历
during the Great Fire of London. We'll be uncovering all of that. And we'll have characters and stories that have been totally forgotten but shouldn't have been. This week, we're looking at a terror attack that shocked New York, that cost American lives, caused millions of dollars of damage to buildings across Manhattan, that led to the establishment of new security agencies, and that helped push the United States towards war.
伦敦大火是怎样的体验。我们将揭开这一切。我们还将讲述那些被彻底遗忘、但本不该被遗忘的人物和故事。本周，我们将关注一起震惊纽约的恐怖袭击，它夺走了美国人的生命，对曼哈顿各地的建筑造成了数百万美元的破坏，导致了新安全机构的建立，并推动美国走向战争。
But it's not 9-11. This is the Black Tom explosion of 1916, the story of a massive sabotage campaign as Germany made a desperate effort to keep America from helping the Allies during the First World War. And the cast of characters for this story involves playboy diplomats, there's a stranded sailor, an opera singer who's managing a brothel in New York, and there's a hapless spy who leaves secret documents on a train. So join us on Journey Through Time and hear a clip from the Black Tom story at the end of this episode. Only a boy, you ship batterer, When you launched your boat, no king was younger than you.
但这不是9·11。这是1916年的黑汤姆大爆炸（Black Tom explosion），这是一个关于大规模破坏活动的故事，当时德国为了阻止美国在第一次世界大战期间帮助盟军而作出了绝望的努力。这个故事的人物阵容包括花花公子外交官、一名滞留的水手、一位在纽约经营妓院的女高音歌唱家，以及一个在火车上落下机密文件的倒霉间谍。因此，请加入我们的《穿越时空》，并在本集末尾收听“黑汤姆”故事的一个片段。你这个击船手，当你下水时，没有哪个国王比你更年轻。
So those were lines, lovely lines written by a praise singer about the very young, very impressive, very frightening son of Svein Forkbeard. And this is a man familiar to anybody who enjoys anecdotes about waves, because he is a young man called Knute. And Knute came with his father Svein to England in 1013. He's probably battle hardened even at that point. He'd probably been on previous raids. His father has been struck in a dream by St Edmund with a pole
所以这些是赞美诗歌手为斯韦恩·福克伯德（Svein Forkbeard）那个非常年轻、非常令人印象深刻、非常可怕的儿子写下的美妙诗句。这是一个熟悉浪潮轶事的人所熟知的人物，因为他是一个名叫克努特（Knute）的年轻人。克努特于1013年随其父斯韦恩来到英格兰。即使在那时，他也可能已经久经沙场。他可能参加过之前的袭击。他的父亲在梦中被圣埃德蒙用一根杆子击中
and has died. And so Knut is now the leader of, well, he's the leader of what? Is he the leader merely of a war band or does he want to be the claimant to a grand North Sea empire that includes England as well as Denmark and Norway? He's got a dilemma, hasn't he Tom? Does he give up and basically go back to Denmark or even at this young age, does he go for it as his father was going to do?
而死。所以克努特现在是……好吧，他是谁的领袖？他仅仅是一支战帮的领袖，还是想成为一个包括英格兰以及丹麦和挪威在内的宏伟北海帝国的继承人？他面临着一个两难境地，不是吗，汤姆？他是放弃并基本上回到丹麦，还是即便在如此年轻的时候，也要像他父亲原本打算做的那样放手一搏？
Well, I think he actually does both. So he does withdraw from England in the wake of his father's death. But as a sign that he will be back, remember that the English nobleman, particularly around Mercia, had given him hostages. So Canute takes these hostages and he maims them, cuts off their hands, blinds them and dumps them all on the beach at sandwich. So, you know, that's, that's not fun. And he then goes back to Denmark and he, you know, he's a chip off the old block. He does what his father would have done, which is to use his rank and his power as King of
嗯，我想他实际上两样都做了。因此，在他父亲死后，他确实撤出了英格兰。但作为他会回来的信号，请记住，英格兰贵族，特别是麦西亚（Mercia）周围的贵族，曾向他提供过人质。因此，克努特抓走了这些人质，并残害了他们——砍掉他们的双手，弄瞎他们的双眼，然后把他们全部扔在三明治海滩（sandwich）上。所以，你知道，这可一点也不好玩。然后他回到了丹麦，而且，你知道，他真是有其父必有其风。他做了他父亲会做的事，那就是利用他作为丹麦
Denmark to marshal another great invasion fleet. And he also sends agents to England to secure pledges of loyalty from all the various Danish communities there, particularly in East Anglia and particularly around the Humber, because that's where the settlement is the deepest. And he also recruits large numbers of mercenaries. And it said in a biography of him by a guy who's very keen on him, there were so many kinds of shield. It was easy to believe that troops drawn from all the nations of the world were with him.
国王的地位和权力，集结另一支庞大的入侵舰队。他还派遣特工前往英格兰，确保当地各个丹麦人社区（特别是在东盎格利亚和亨伯河一带，因为那里的定居最深）对他的忠诚宣誓。他还招募了大量的雇佣兵。一个非常崇拜他的传记作家在书中写道，当时有各种各样的盾牌，以至于很容易让人相信，来自世界各国的军队都与他同在。
And among them is Thorkell, who has now abandoned a thread for good. So he's got these terrifying, massive lads behind him. They're tall, you know, they, they think nothing of pelting archbishops with oxen bones and they are sailing for England. And they arrive in the summer of 1015. Ethelred is dying, but not quite dead. So the question in everybody's mind is this, is it going to be Edmund Ironside who succeeds his heir or is Cnut going to finish what Svane Fortby had started and basically assimilate England into the world of the Scandinavian Empire? And Cnut and Edmund go kind of hammer and tongs and by the time that Ethered finally
其中就包括索克尔（Thorkell），他现在已经彻底抛弃了埃塞尔雷德。所以他的身后有这群可怕、高大的壮汉。他们个子很高，你知道，他们把用牛骨砸大主教当成家常便饭，而且他们正乘船驶向英格兰。他们在1015年夏天抵达。埃塞尔雷德垂死，但尚未咽气。所以每个人心中都有这样一个问题：究竟是埃德蒙·伊恩赛德作为他的继承人继位，还是克努特将完成斯韦恩·福特比未竟的事业，基本上将英格兰同化进斯堪的纳维亚帝国的世界？克努特和埃德蒙进行了激烈的搏杀，当埃塞尔雷德终于在
dies on the 23rd of April 1016, the country is effectively divided in two. So Cnut has Northumbria and East Anglia and Edmund has Wessex and neither side can really defeat the other. And I think that the fact that Edmund has been able to secure Wessex indicates that Ethered actually had been a failure as a king. He could have fought as his son did and he didn't. And now the country is divided.
1016年4月23日去世时，这个国家实际上已经被一分为二。克努特占领了诺森布里亚和东盎格利亚，埃德蒙则控制了威塞克斯，双方谁也无法真正击败对方。我认为，埃德蒙能够保住威塞克斯这一事实表明，埃塞尔雷德作为国王实际上是个失败者。他本可以像他的儿子那样战斗，但他没有。现在国家分裂了。
So there is one key territory which remains up for grabs and that is Mercia. The Midlands. Basically the Midlands. And this is under the rule of an elder man called Edric and he is a very very kind of slippery treacherous opportunist as is conveyed by his nickname which is Strayona or the grabber. So he's very much the little finger of this story isn't he because he's always changing sides and betraying people and basically you never can be entirely sure well he's only on his he's on his own side
因此，还有一个关键领土仍然虚位以待，那就是麦西亚。中部地区。基本上就是中部地区。这片土地在一个名叫埃德里克（Edric）的长老统治下，他是一个非常非常滑头、背信弃义的机会主义者，正如他的绰号“斯特拉约纳”（Strayona）或“掠夺者”所传达的那样。所以他简直就是这个故事里的“小指头”（Littlefinger），因为他总是反复倒戈、背叛他人，基本上你永远无法完全确定——好吧，他只效忠于他自己——
and he is constantly swapping from Edmund to Knute and back again. Yes, he is. So actually the description you get in the Anglo-Saxon Chronicle, it does sound quite like kind of Littlefinger, a man of humble origins, but whose smooth tongue won him wealth and high standing. Endowed as he was with a subtle genius and incredible powers of eloquence, he surpassed all his peers in malice and treachery as well as in pride and cruelty. He's the Captain Bentine of the story. I mean, he's so treacherous that in a way he overdoes it. Right. So first of all, he sides
而且他在埃德蒙和克努特之间不断摇摆。是的，确实如此。所以实际上你在《盎格鲁-撒克逊编年史》中看到的描述，听起来确实很像“小指头”——一个出身卑微，但凭借三寸不烂之舌赢得了财富和崇高地位的男人。他天赋异禀，既有精明的才智，又有令人难以置信的雄辩能力，在恶意与背叛以及傲慢与残忍方面，他超越了所有的同龄人。他是这个故事里的本丁船长（Captain Bentine）。我的意思是，他太背信弃义了，以至于在某种程度上他做得过头了。没错。首先，他站在
with Knute and tries to have Edmund assassinated. Then he goes over to Edmund, then he goes back to Canute and then he comes back to Edmund. He's a weathervane. He is tracking the shift in fortunes between Canute and Edmund as they fight each other over England. And the climactic clash takes place in the autumn of 1016 on the 18th of October at a site in Essex called Assondon. It's a very, very hard fought battle, but then treachery in the English lines. Edric Strayona, the grabber, has swapped sides yet again. In mid-battle. In mid-battle. can it wins? Prey singers celebrate his great victory at Aschengdon you worked well in the shield war warrior King Brown was the flesh of bodies
克努特一边，企图刺杀埃德蒙。然后他投奔埃德蒙，接着又回到克努特身边，然后又回到了埃德蒙那里。他是个风向标。他在追踪克努特和埃德蒙为争夺英格兰而战时命运的转变。最激烈的冲突发生在1016年秋天的10月18日，地点在埃塞克斯的一个叫阿森顿（Assondon）的地方。这是一场非常非常惨烈的战斗，但随后英军阵线出现了叛变。埃德里克·斯特拉约纳（Edric Strayona），那个掠夺者，再次倒戈了。在战斗中。在战斗中。克努特赢了？赞美诗歌手们庆祝他在阿申顿的伟大胜利：你在盾战中干得很好，勇士国王，褐色的躯体成了
Served to the carrion birds great line, but Edmund, you know, his sides are not fashioned out of iron for nothing No, he's not gonna surrender and in the end the two men agreed that they will divide England Edmund keeps Wessex but Canute gets mercy and therefore effectively everything north of the River Thames and we've promised toilet-based misadventure. Edmund does not long outlive the agreement so on the 30th of November 1016 he dies possibly of wounds suffered in battle but another account says that he was murdered while sitting on the toilet. It's sort of true, isn't it? That basically everybody who dies in this period, there's always an account
给食腐鸟类的食物。好台词，但是埃德蒙，你知道，他的身躯不是白用铁打造的。不，他不会投降，最后两人同意将英格兰一分为二。埃德蒙保留威塞克斯，但克努特得到了麦西亚，因此实际上获得了泰晤士河以北的所有领土。我们曾承诺过会有与厕所有关的险事。埃德蒙没有在这个协议之后活多久，所以在1016年11月30日，他去世了，可能是死于战斗中受到的伤，但另一份记录称他在坐马桶时被谋杀了。这某种程度上是真的，对吧？基本上这一时期所有死去的名人，总有一份记录
that claims that it was while they were relieving themselves in some way. Not everyone, but it's certainly, but it's a feature. I think the features, isn't it? So we're in 1016, exactly half a century before the very famous conquest of 1066 but this is a conquest just as complete and Just as remarkable in some ways as the Norman conquest. This is a Danish conquest Yeah, the dynasty of Alfred the great has been it appears definitively driven off the throne and the Danes
声称他们是在某种程度上释放自己时丧命的。并非所有人，但这绝对是一个特征。我觉得这是一个特点，不是吗？所以我们来到了1016年，恰好是那场著名的1066年征服前半个世纪的时候，但这也是一场同样彻底、在某些方面同样非凡的征服，不亚于诺曼征服。这是一场丹麦人的征服。是的，伟大者阿尔弗雷德的王朝显然已经被彻底驱逐出王位，而丹麦人——
I mean they really are the masters of England now under Knute. Yeah, they are. And Knute is obviously very keen on killing as many of the Curda King as the dynasty of Alfred the Great as he can. So Edmund's younger brother, he is murdered on Knute's orders. This still leaves some of them on the scene. So, uh, we've mentioned the two sons of Ethelred and Emma who have fled to
我的意思是，他们在克努特的统治下，真正成为了英格兰的主人。是的，他们是。克努特显然非常热衷于尽可能多地杀害库尔德国王（指阿尔弗雷德大帝的韦塞克斯王朝）以及阿尔弗雷德大帝王朝的人。所以埃德蒙的弟弟在克努特的命令下被谋杀了。这使得现场仍然留下了一些人。所以，我们提到了埃塞尔雷德和埃玛逃往
Normandy. So they are Edmund's half brothers, Edward and Alfred. So they are in Normandy and can you can't get his hands on them. Edmund, I don't know, side himself has left two sons. Canute sends them to Sweden in the expectation that they will be murdered. Yeah. That's his plan. So it's a bit like Claudia sending Hamlet to England to be murdered. Same kind of idea.
诺曼底的两个儿子。所以他们是埃德蒙同父异母的兄弟，爱德华和阿尔弗雷德。他们身在诺曼底，克努特抓不到他们。埃德蒙·伊恩赛德本人留下了两个儿子。克努特把他们送到瑞典，指望他们会被谋杀。是的。这就是他的计划。所以这有点像克劳迪斯把哈姆雷特送到英格兰去被谋杀。一样的套路。
The king of Sweden doesn't murder them, but sends them on to Kiv and from there they end up in Hungary. Right. And the eldest of them, a guy called Edward will grow up to be known as Edward the exile. So there are still Koda King has out there, but there are none now in England. You know, since we raised the comparison with the Norman conquest, here's the crucial question. What happens in England?
瑞典国王没有谋杀他们，而是把他们送到基辅，并从那里最终流落到匈牙利。没错。他们中的长者，一个叫爱德华的人长大后被称为“流亡者爱德华”（Edward the exile）。所以外面仍然有库尔德国王的后裔，但现在英格兰境内已经没有了。你知道，既然我们提到了与诺曼征服的对比，这里有个关键问题。英格兰发生了什么？
So my sense is that actually Knute the top jobs, obviously he gives to his own supporters to Danes. So he keeps the heartland of Wessex, but Thorkell, the very tall guy who's swapped sides a few times, but has now ended up on the winning side. He gets East Anglia and another day in a guy called Eric gets Northumbria. So they're parceling out the kingdom rather as William will go on to do after 1066. And these guys aren't elder men like the Anglo-Saxons. There's something new, aren't they?
所以我的感觉是，克努特把最高职位显然都给了他自己的支持者，也就是丹麦人。所以他保留了威塞克斯的核心地带，但索克尔——那个换了几次阵营但最终站在胜利者一边的高个子男人——得到了东盎格利亚，另一个丹麦人埃里克（Eric）得到了诺森布里亚。所以他们正在瓜分王国，就像威廉在1066年后将要做的那样。而且这些人不像盎格鲁-撒克逊人的长老（ealdormen）那样。他们是某种新鲜事物，不是吗？
Yarls. Yeah, which becomes Anglicised to Earls. Right. So there's the same route. You can see elder men and Earl. I mean, it's the same kind of route, but to be an Earl is to live in a country that has been conquered by the Danes. Okay. There is one surviving elder man or Earl we want to call him and that is Edric Strayona, the grabber.
伯爵（Yarls）。是的，后来被英语化为 Earls。没错。所以这是同源的。你可以看到ealdorman和Earl。我的意思是，它们是同一种词源，但成为一个伯爵意味着生活在一个被丹麦人征服的国家里。好吧。还有一个幸存的长老或伯爵，随你怎么称呼他，那就是埃德里克·斯特拉约纳，那个掠夺者。
But again, as with William, who does try to keep some English lords in situ, but they're always rebelling against him. And so ultimately he just gets rid of them all. Edric is too slippery, too treacherous. He starts the scheme again and can it's not having that. And so he has Edric murdered in London on Christmas day 1017 and his head is put on a spike on the battlements of London and his body is thrown over the city battlements to serve As food for the dogs. That's exactly the kind of thing that you look for in a series like this, isn't it? Yes, what about so that's about the jobs. What about the crucial thing, which is about the money?
但同样，就像威廉确实试图在原地保留一些英国领主，但他们总是背叛他，所以最终他干脆把他们全清理掉了一样。埃德里克太滑头、太背信弃义了。他又开始搞阴谋诡计，克努特可不吃那一套。因此，他在1017年的圣诞节那天让人在伦敦谋杀了埃德里克，并将他的头颅挂在伦敦城垛的尖桩上，他的身体则被扔过城墙，作为狗的食物。这正是你在这种系列节目中所期待的那种情节，不是吗？是的，那么——关于职位就是这样。关键的事情是什么呢，关于钱？
The attraction of England is that it's so rich. All of these men, these mercenaries who have flocked to Knute's banners, they have done so because they thought they were going to get the money. What happens to the wealth of England? Is it basically just parceled out and looted? Can I quote from Millennium? Do you going to quote from yourself? I'm going to quote myself.
英格兰的吸引力在于它太富有了。所有这些人，这些蜂拥至克努特旗下的雇佣兵，他们之所以这么做，是因为他们以为自己能分到钱。英格兰的财富怎么处理了？它基本上是被瓜分并洗劫一空了吗？我可以引用《千禧年》（Millennium）里的的话吗？你要引用你自己的话吗？我要引用我自己的话。
Oh, gone. In Canute, yeah, the larcenous instincts that had long propelled generations of Northmen across the seas were set to attain their apotheosis for he had his sword at the throat of an entire kingdom. So think of all that gold. Yeah. That Danes over the course of Ethelred's reign had been extorting. There's millions of coins. Well, Ethelred's ability to do that had depended upon the apparatus of English governance. This is what enables him to raise the money. And now that apparatus of English governance is Knut's to command.
哦，说吧。在克努特身上，长期驱使几代北方人跨越大海的掠夺本能即将达到顶峰，因为他的剑正架在整个王国的喉咙上。所以想想所有的那些黄金。是的。丹麦人在埃塞尔雷德统治期间一直在勒索黄金。有数百万枚硬币。好吧，埃塞尔雷德做到这一点的能力依赖于英格兰的统治机构。这就是他能够筹集资金的原因。现在，英格兰的统治机构归克努特指挥了。
So he can do with it what he wants and in the tax year of 1018 he sets the tax rate at a hundred percent and It takes his agents months and months to extort this but by the end of the year essentially the entire Income of the kingdom for that year has vanished into Canute's treasure chests So Rachel Reeves can only dream of such rich pickings. Regular listeners will be disappointed if I don't mention Dennis Healy at this point in his 83% top rate of tax in the early 1970s. So Dennis Healy exceeded only by Canute.
所以他可以随心所欲地处理它，在1018税收年度，他将税率定为百分之百，他的特工花了几个月又几个月的时间来勒索这笔钱，但到年底，基本上该王国那一年的全部收入都消失在了克努特的国库里。所以雷切尔·里夫斯（Rachel Reeves）只能梦想有这样丰厚的收获了。如果我不在这时提到丹尼斯·希利（Dennis Healy）在20世纪70年代早期高达83%的最高税率，忠实的听众一定会感到失望的。所以丹尼斯·希利只有克努特能超越。
But so here's the question. Top jobs given to Danes, the money parceled out an entire, you know, basically the entire income of England for a year taken and put into Danish coffers. Why is it therefore that nobody remembers the conquest of 1016 when it must have been psychologically pretty devastating, particularly for the English elite, many of whom must have lost not just their money, but their power, their status, their prestige, their self-worth, all of those kinds of things.
所以问题来了。高级职位给了丹麦人，金钱被瓜分，整个国家（你知道的，基本上是英格兰一年的全部收入）被拿走并放入了丹麦的国库，为什么没有人记住1016年的征服呢？当时这在心理上一定相当具毁灭性，特别是对于英国精英阶层来说，他们中的许多人不仅失去了金钱，还失去了权力、地位、声望、自我价值感以及所有诸如此类的东西。
I think it's partly because the English are actually very familiar with the Danes and you could talk of a kind of Anglo-Danish world reaching back decades, maybe centuries. These people, their languages and now that the Danes have become Christian, their religion, there is scope there for them to merge. So culturally it's not a shock. I mean, it is a shock, but it's not as big a shock as it will be to be conquered by people speaking French. That would be a shock, yeah.
我想部分原因是因为英国人实际上对丹麦人非常熟悉，你可以谈论一个可以追溯到几十年前、甚至几个世纪的盎格鲁-丹麦世界。这些人，他们的语言，以及现在丹麦人已经皈依基督教，他们的宗教信仰，这些都为他们融为一体提供了空间。所以在文化上这不是一个震撼。我的意思是，这是一个震撼，但没有被说法语的人征服那么大。那将是一个震撼，是的。
But I think also, Canute may have conquered England, but he displays something akin to a kind of cultural cringe. So in 1018, which is the year that he's extorting his 100% tax rate, he allows himself to be persuaded by the Archbishop of York, who's a very distinguished scholar, very holy man, into upholding the laws of the Kyrgyzstan. So the laws of Edgar and of Ethelred essentially, you know, that he, he promises he will rule as though he belonged to the dynasty of, of Kurdic and of Alfred the great. And the reason that he's happy to do this is because he does not want to
但我认为，克努特可能征服了英格兰，但他表现出了一种类似于文化自卑的东西。所以在1018年，也就是他勒索100%税率的那一年，他允许自己被约克大主教——一位非常杰出的学者、非常神圣的人——说服，去维护库尔德王朝的法律。所以基本上是埃德加和埃塞尔雷德的法律，你知道，他承诺他将像属于库尔德和伟大者阿尔弗雷德王朝一样进行统治。他之所以乐意这样做，是因为他不想
rule as a Viking warlord, he wants to rule England as a Christian King. Um, he, you know, he's grown up surrounded by English bishops in Denmark, Harold Bluetooth and Svein Fortbeard had not allowed bishops from Germany to serve there because the Germans are a far more present threat the Saxon monarchy. So all the bishops in Denmark basically are English and the Archbishop of York Wolfstan, he can serve Knut as a kind of Gandalf was a Merlin or a Merlin. Yeah. He's at his side. And this sense of intimacy that Knute has with his new kingdom is evident in his very bed, because although he is
以维京军阀的身份统治，他想以基督教国王的身份统治英格兰。嗯，你知道，他在丹麦是在英国主教的环绕中长大的，哈罗德·蓝牙（Harold Bluetooth）和斯韦恩·福特贝德（Svein Fortbeard）不允许来自德国的主教在那里服务，因为德国人是对撒克逊君主制更现实的威胁。所以丹麦所有的主教基本上都是英国人，约克大主教沃尔斯坦（Wolfstan）可以作为一种甘道夫或梅林来服务克努特，或者说一个梅林。是的。他在他身旁。克努特与他的新王国的这种亲密感在他的私生活中显而易见，因为尽管他是
a Christian, he remains sufficiently a Northman that he thinks nothing of having two wives, both of them kind of English in his bed. And the question of what exactly these two women, what exactly their status are is highly contested. Okay. So are they both wives? Is one of them a concubine? So Pauline Stafford, who's kind of the great expert on, on the role of queens
一个基督徒，但他依然保留了足够的北方人特质，以至于他毫不犹豫地让两个妻子——两个某种程度上都是英国人的女人——同床共枕。这两个女人究竟是谁，她们的地位究竟是什么，这个问题备受争议。好吧。所以她们都是妻子吗？其中一个是妾吗？所以波林·斯塔福德（Pauline Stafford），作为11世纪英格兰王后角色的伟大专家，她说妾和妻之间的区别太绝对了，无法捕捉这种不断变化的情况。我描述这两个女人（这两个妻子、妾、王后，不管她们是什么人）是谁时，原因就会显而易见了。所以第一个人，她来自北安普顿，对吧？她是一个长老的女儿。她有个绝妙的名字叫埃尔夫吉富（Elf Gifu）。
in the 11th century England, she says concubine wife is too stark a distinction to capture this shifting situation. And the reason for that will be evident when I describe who these two women, these two wives, concubines, queens, whatever, who they are. So the first one, she's from Northampton, isn't she? And she's an elder one's daughter. And she has the brilliant name of Elf Gifu. Which confusingly is the same name that Emma, Arthur Redd's wife from Normandy had been
令人困惑的是，这与埃玛（Emma，诺曼底的埃塞尔雷德之妻）来到英格兰时被赋予的名字相同，这就是为什么我们不需要那样称呼她。是的，所以埃尔夫吉富在斯韦恩入侵的早期就嫁给了克努特，几乎可以肯定这是一场王朝联姻。正如我们所见，她可能与显赫的麦西亚家族有亲属关系。她是他们与丹麦人结盟的一种誓约，克努特和埃尔夫吉富相处得似乎非常好。所以埃尔夫吉富非常非常快地怀孕了，生下一个男孩，为了纪念他可爱的祖父，取名斯韦恩。1015年，克努特带着这个婴儿把她送回了丹麦。克努特也回到了丹麦，让她再次怀孕，她生下了另一个
given when she came to England, which is why we need to not call her that. Yeah, so Elf Gifu had married Canute in the early days of Svein's invasion and almost certainly this was a kind of dynastic marriage. So as we will see, she is probably related to the leading Mercian family. She's a kind of pledge of their, of their alliance with the Danes and Knut and Elfgifu seem to have got on tremendously well. So Elfgifu gets pregnant very, very quickly, gives birth to a boy who is named Svein after his adorable grandfather and in 1015 Knut sends her back to Denmark with the baby. Knute returns to Denmark as well, gets her pregnant again, and she gives birth to another
男孩，名叫哈罗德，由于他在12世纪的所作所为，后来被称为“足毛者”（Harefoot）。所以他在这个时期不叫足毛者，但我们会这样称呼他。我们应该这样称呼他。我们有太多叫哈罗德的人了。与其他哈罗德区分开。是的。所以克努特显然非常尊重埃尔夫吉富，不仅因为她能为他生下儿子，还因为她是一个政治操作者。当他返回英格兰去对抗埃德蒙·伊恩赛德时，他把埃尔夫吉富留在
boy, Harold, who in due course in the 12th century will come to be called Harefoot. So he's not called Harefoot in this period, but we'll call him that. We should call him that. We've got too many Harolds. From the other Harolds. Yeah. So Canute clearly respects Elf Gifu very highly, not just as a woman who can give him sons, but also as a political operator. And when he returns to England to fight Edmund Ironside, he leaves Elf Gifu to
丹麦为他管理部分领地。没错。而在1030年，也就是说大概十年或更久之后，他对她的信任有一个更引人注目的例子。因为到了这个时候，他的大儿子斯韦恩已经是一个十几岁的少年了，克努特心想，我很想让他成为挪威国王。于是他派埃尔夫吉富、斯韦恩和一大支战帮前往挪威去征服它，并让斯韦恩作为国王驻在那里。诚然，事情进展得并不是非常顺利。埃尔夫吉富确实征服了挪威，但她统治得非常非常严厉。挪威人发动了叛乱，在1035年，她和斯韦恩被赶了出去，斯韦恩不久后
administer part of Denmark for him. Right. And in 1030, so that's kind of a decade and more on, there's an even more striking example of his faith in her. Because by this point, his elder son, Svein, is a teenager and Knut thinks, I'd quite like him to be King of Norway. So he sends Alf Gifu, Svein and a big war band off to Norway to conquer it and install Svein as king. And it's true that it doesn't go brilliantly. Elf Gifu does conquer Norway, but she rules very, very harshly. The Norwegians rebel and in 1035, she and Svein are kicked out and Svein dies soon after
死于战斗中受到的伤。所以埃尔夫吉富回到了丹麦，但她仍然是现场一个非常具有影响力的存在，并且正如我们稍后将看到的，她手中仍然有牌可打。好吧，让我们把她放在一边。所以这就是埃尔夫吉富和她的儿子，也就是足毛者。哈罗德·哈里福特（Harold Harefoot）。是的。现在你说克努特有两个妻子，这确实是一个
of wounds sustained in battle. So Elf Gifu is back in Denmark, but she's still very much a kind of potent presence on the scene and still has cards to play as we will see in due course. Well, let's say, let's just park her to one side. So there's Elf Gifu and her son who is Harefoot. Harold Harefoot. Yeah. Now you said that there were two wives of Knute and this really is a
大转折，因为他娶了他父亲昔日的对手、埃塞尔雷德的遗孀。他娶了诺曼底的埃玛。他在1017年结的婚。所以她一定比他大不少吧？她依然风韵犹存。好吧，这倒是个好消息。正如我们将看到的。所以你可以说这是典型的维京行为，与你被击败的敌人的女人同床共枕。没错。但我确信那是动力的一部分，但本质上克努特娶她是，因为她曾嫁给埃塞尔雷德并被涂油加冕为王后，因此她是连结延续了数个世纪的西撒克逊君主制传统的活生生的纽带。埃玛的母亲实际上是个丹麦人。所以她有一半丹麦血统，大概还会说丹麦语。
twist to his great twist because he has married the widow of his father's former adversary, Ethelred. He is married Emma of Normandy. He has in 1017. So she must be a fair bit older than him, right? She's still very new, Bile. Okay, that's good to know. As we will see. And so you could say this is kind of classic Viking behavior, taking to bed
但她对克努特的价值基本上在于，尽管她有一半丹麦血统、一半诺曼血统，她是一位英国王后。她是英格兰的化身。通过娶她，他在某种程度上就是娶了英格兰。因此，他对她的婚姻得到了教会的祝福。这是她和埃尔夫吉富之间最大的不同点。埃尔夫吉富的婚姻没有得到教会的祝福。不需要。这不是一个教会必定会祝福每一场婚礼的时代。但埃玛的婚姻得到了祝福，这使她能够说：我是克努特合法的妻子，我为他生下的任何孩子，都有权继承英格兰的王位。
the woman of your defeated enemy. Right. But I'm sure that that's a kind of part of the dynamic, but essentially Canute is marrying her because she had been married to Ethel Red and anointed as his queen and so she is a living link to that tradition of West Saxon monarchy going back centuries and centuries. Emma's mother had actually been a Dane. So she's half Danish and probably speaks Danish.
这说明了克努特政治上的敏感和成熟，不是吗？他不仅仅是一个维京军阀。他，正如你在笔记中所写的，曾涉足血海。他是靠武力和恐怖统治的。他赢得了王冠。然而一旦他做到了这一点，他却有足够的技巧去认识到有些延续性是他想要保留的。他想要与
But her value to Canute is essentially that she is, even though she's half Danish, half Norman, she is an English queen. She's the embodiment of England. And by marrying her, he is in a sense marrying England. And so his marriage to her is blessed by the church. And this is the big point of difference between her and Alf Giffo. Alf Giffo's marriage had not been blessed by the church. Doesn't need to be. This isn't an age where it's a given that the church will bless every wedding. But the fact that Emma's has been enables her to say, I am Knute's legitimate wife and any children that I give him, they are entitled to the throne of England.
现有的传统合作。他显然想要——“安抚”这个词用得不对，但归根结底他知道他将不得不与英国人合作。英格兰是他的战利品，他希望它在他的宗主权下繁荣昌盛。我想，你知道的，他也是个基督徒，这意味着他和英国人民有很多共同点。让我想起的人物是奥古斯都。他不是一个有着类似成就的人，但他那种在必要时毫不留情地残暴，然后在不再需要时把那一面搁置一边、将自己塑造成和平化身的能力。
So this speaks to Knute's political sensitivity and sophistication, doesn't it? He's not just a Viking warlord. He has, you know, as you put it in your notes, he's waded through blood. He has ruled by the sword and by terror. He's won his crown. And yet once he's done that, he is sufficiently skillful to recognize that there are continuities he wants to preserve. He wants to work with
非常非常强大。这只是出色的政治手腕，不是吗，汤姆？所以这个家伙，正如你所说，曾涉足血海，他允许约克大主教沃尔斯坦以他的名义撰写法律，宣扬谦逊和自我克制的基督教美德。正如沃尔斯坦所写，克努特也署了名：一个人越有权势或地位越高，他为不当行为赎罪的程度就必须越深，无论对上帝还是对人都是如此。克努特剥夺了基督教世界中最古老的王室血统的继承权，但他却成为了——我很高兴地说——一个经常造访威尔顿（Wilton）这座经过修复
the existing traditions. He clearly wants to conciliate is the wrong word, but ultimately he knows he will have to work with the English. England is his prize and he wants it to thrive under his overlordship. And I guess, you know, he's also Christian, which means he's got a lot in common with the people of England. The figure he reminds me of is Augustus. He's not a man of similar achievement, but the willingness to be unspeakably brutal where necessary and then when it's no longer necessary to park that side and to kind of promote himself as a figure of peace.
和重建的修女院的常客。他和埃玛一起骑马到那里，在神圣的禁地外恭敬地下马，走了进去，并在韦塞克斯王室女性的陵墓中祈祷。他是一个维京人，一个来自世界冰冷边缘的北方人。但在1027年，令人惊奇的是，他从统治他在挪威、丹麦、英格兰缔造的这个庞大北海帝国的政务中抽身出来。我的意思是，这已经很多了，但他能够去罗马朝圣，在那里，在古老城市的中心，跪在圣彼得的陵墓前，用他的传记作家的话说，恳切地在上帝面前为圣彼得的特别恩宠而祈祷。
Very, very formidable. That's just good politics, isn't it Tom? Right. So this guy who, as you said, had waded through blood, he allows Wolfstam, the Archbishop of York, to write laws in his name that proclaim the Christian virtues of humility and self-restraint. So as Wolfstam writes, and Canute puts his name to this, for the mightier or of higher rank a man is, so the deeper must he atone for wrongdoing, both to God and to men. Knute has disinherited the oldest royal line in Christendom, but he becomes, I'm delighted to say, a regular visitor to the restored
他去那里不仅仅是为了祈祷。他去是因为在1027年的那个复活节，一位新的德意志皇帝正在罗马加冕。克努特在那个加冕典礼上占据了皇帝身边的荣誉席位。对于一个异教军阀的曾孙来说，这是一个了不起的成就。所以，抛开那些过去的东西，你知道的，带着他的大坟冢和所有那些东西，在罗马受到皇帝和教皇的最高荣誉和尊重。从这个意义上说，这有点查理曼大帝的方面，不是吗？一个最终来自野蛮异教血统的人，现在正站在罗马
and rebuilt nunnery at Wilton. And he rides there with Emma and he dismounts respectfully outside the holy precincts and he walks in and he prays among the tombs of the women of the house of Wessex. And he is a Viking, a Northman from the frozen limits of the world. But in 1027, amazingly, he takes time off from ruling this great North Sea empire that he's forged in Norway, Denmark, England. I mean, it's a lot, but he's able to go on pilgrimage to Rome and there in the heart of the ancient city to kneel before the tomb of St. Peter and in the words of his biographer, diligently to speak St. Peter's special favor before God.
教皇和恺萨的城市里，赢得他的同龄人的尊重和认可。是的。我的意思是，克努特是一个非常——我知道这是一个暴力的时代，他也很暴力，但作为一个政治家、一个政治家，他是一个非常令人印象深刻的人物。嗯，人们常说阿尔弗雷德大帝是唯一被称为大帝的英国国王或至少是英格兰国王，但其实不是。
And he hasn't just gone there to pray. He's gone because that Easter of 1027, a new German emperor is being crowned in Rome. And Canute at that coronation has the place of honor at the emperor's side. And it is an amazing achievement for the great grandson of a pagan warlord. So, gone the old, you know, with his great mounds and his, all that stuff to be received with the utmost honor and respect in Rome by both the emperor and the pope. So in that sense, there's a slight Charlemagne aspect to this, isn't there? Somebody from ultimately a barbarian pagan lineage who now is standing there in Rome
克努特也被赋予了那个称号，就像查理曼被称为查理大帝一样。是的。而且是的，我的意思是，我认为他的征服壮举和之后的治国方略都非常非常强大。就像英格兰在击败丹麦人的阿尔弗雷德统治下复苏一样，它也在本身就是丹麦人的克努特统治下复苏了。我想显而易见的原因是，首先克努特没有像那样强加100%的税率。
in the city of the pope and the Caesars, you know, being winning respect and recognition from his peers. Yeah. I mean, Canute is a tremendously, you know, I know this is a violent age and he's very violently, but as a politician, as a, as a statesman, he's a very impressive figure. Well, it's often said that Alfred the Great is the only English King or at least King of England to be called the great, but he isn't.
你知道，那是一次性的，而且丹麦人不再袭击英格兰了，因为这里正由丹麦人统治。是的。因此，英格兰经济、乡村和基础设施有了恢复的空间。而且克努特的政权似乎也很稳固，因为他有埃尔夫吉富为他生的儿子哈罗德·哈里福特，但他还和埃玛生了一个儿子，被赐予了一个绝妙的名字——哈代克努特（Harthacnut）。
Canute has also been given that subra K as Charlemagne had Charles the great. Yeah. And yeah, I mean, I think, I think his, his feats of conquest and then a statecraft are very, very formidable. And just as England had recovered under Alfred, who had beaten the Danes, so also it recovers under Canute, who is himself a Dane. And I guess the obvious reason for that is that it's firstly that Canute is not kind of imposing his hundred percent tax rate.
是的。因此，克努特如此强大，他统治着这个庞大的帝国，他有两个儿子，这使得库尔德国王（阿尔弗雷德大帝血统）重返英格兰王位的愿景显得完全不可信。所以你有埃德蒙·伊恩赛德的儿子们，包括流亡者爱德华，他们远在遥远的匈牙利，他们基本上，你知道，他们是东欧贵族，他们甚至都不会说英语，对吧？然后你有埃塞尔雷德和埃玛的两个儿子。也就是爱德华和阿尔弗雷德，他们在诺曼底。
You know, that was that was a one off, but also the Danes are no longer aiding England because it's being ruled by the Danes. Yeah. And so there is scope for the English economy and the English countryside and English infrastructure to recover. And it also seems that Canute's regime is secure because he has Harold Hereford, his son, by Alf Giffo, but he's also fathered a son on Emma who gets given the wonderful name of Halfa Canute.
诚然，只隔着海峡，但他们带有绝对失败者的印记。而真正说“是的，他们是失败者”的人，正是他们自己的母亲。嗯，因为这符合她的利益。她回到了英格兰，当然是这样。当然是这样。因为她支持的儿子是哈代克努特，她和克努特生的那个儿子。好吧。我的意思是，他是那个准备好并排队准备登上英格兰王位的人。所以难怪埃玛现在所有的注意力都集中在英格兰和丹麦上。她对她在诺曼底流亡的埃塞尔雷德的两个儿子其实没有任何兴趣，甚至对诺曼底本身也没有兴趣。她已经继续前进了。因为当时的诺曼底本身看起来并不是一个非常强大的命题，因为它变得四分五裂。
Yeah. And so the fact that Canute is so strong, he rules this great empire, he has two sons, it makes the prospect of any return to the English throne of the Kyrgyz King, the line of Alfred the Great, seem utterly implausible. So you've got the sons of Edmund Ironside, including Edward the exile, they are off in distant Hungary, they are basically, you know, they're East European aristocrats They don't even speak English, right? And then you have a threads two sons by Emma. So that is Edward and Alfred They are in Normandy
它屈服于法国病。是的。所以是在1026年，也就是克努特去罗马朝圣的前一年，埃玛的兄弟理查二世（理查好人），他在诺曼底统治了很长时间，去世了。他有两个儿子，这两个儿子为了遗产大打出手，哥哥赢了。他统治了不到一年。又是那种戏剧性的死亡之一。也许他又中毒了。我们真的不知道。接着继承他的是他的弟弟，名叫罗贝尔（Robert）。罗贝尔相当能干，他让诺曼底恢复了某种
It's true only across the channel, but they have the stamp of absolute losers and the person who really says yeah They're losers is their own mother. Well, because it's in her interest. She's back in England. Of course, it is. Of course it is. Because the son that she's backing is half canoe, the one she's had by canoe. Right. I mean, he's the one who's kind of ready and lined up to sit on the English throne. So it's not surprising that Emma's focus now is all on England and all on Denmark. And she doesn't really have any interest in her two sons by Athelred who are in exile in Normandy or indeed actually in Normandy itself. She's been to that she's moved on from it. Because Normandy itself at this point does not look a terribly formidable proposition because it is it's become bitterly divided.
健康的秩序。但随后，令人惊奇且怪异的是，他去朝圣了，不是去罗马，而是去耶路撒冷，这非常非常危险。我的意思是，这是一段漫长的旅程，风险极大。而更让人觉得不负责任的是，尽管诺曼底公爵罗贝尔确实有一个继承人，但这个继承人首先只有七岁。其次，他是私生子。好吧。这个男孩的名字，多米尼克，是的，女士们先生们，叫威廉。然后，在1035年7月，罗贝尔到了耶路撒冷。
It's succumbed to the French disease. Yeah. So in 1026, so that's a year before Canute goes on his pilgrimage to Rome. Emma's brother, Richard the second, Richard the good, he's ruled for a very long time in Normandy. He dies and he has two sons and these two sons fight over the inheritance and the elder brother wins. He rules for less than a year. One of these kind of dramatic deaths. Maybe he's poisoned again. We don't really know. And he succeeded by his younger brother who is called Robert. And Robert is pretty able, he restores Normandy to a kind of
很好。他从耶路撒冷返回。他正在接近君士坦丁堡，然后他死了。威廉现在是诺曼底公爵了，但他继承的遗产是一场灾难。诺曼底边境的敌人在威胁他，但更严重的是，他自己的公国里的大领主们也在威胁他。相比之下，英格兰绝对是稳定的典范。所以女士们先生们，在克努特及其继承人的统治下，英格兰会继续保持幸福、团结和积极进取吗？
measure of health. But then amazingly, and bizarrely, he goes on pilgrimage not to Rome, but to Jerusalem, which is very, very dangerous. I mean, it's a long way to go and very, very risky. And what makes this seem even more, I think, irresponsible is that although Duke Robert of Normandy does have an heir, this heir is firstly only seven years old. And secondly, he's not legitimate. Okay. And the name of this boy, Dominic, yeah, ladies, gentlemen is William. And then in July, 10 35, Robert has got to Jerusalem.
诺曼底会崩溃吗？这个七岁的小男孩威廉会遭遇什么？他有什么前景？好吧，如果你是《历史余音》（The Rest Is History）俱乐部的会员，你当然可以立刻找到答案，因为你可以收听我们的下一集，内容全部关于诺曼底公国威廉的崛起。但如果你不是《历史余音》俱乐部的会员但你想加入，你可以在theresthistory.com上注册，你知道的，事情就是这样。但是汤姆，对于那些不想这么做的人，我们将在周一回来，带来
Fine. He's returning from Jerusalem. He is approaching Constantinople and he dies. And William is now the Duke of Normandy, but his inheritance is a terrible one. He's menaced by enemies all along the frontiers of Normandy, but even more he is menaced by the great lords of his own dukedom and England by contrast is an absolute model of stability. So ladies and gentlemen, will England remain happy and united and forward looking under
这个史诗故事的下一个扣人心弦的章节。再见。再见。这里是我们之前提到的那个片段。逐渐地，在这个时期，你看到人们对所谓的“具有双重身份的美国人”的担忧日益加剧。这种观点认为，外国移民社区有着分裂的效忠对象。因此，对实质上的效忠测试的需求不断增加。威尔逊发表了一场非常著名的演讲
the reigns of Knute and his successors? Will Normandy fall apart and what will happen to this seven-year-old boy William? What prospects for him? Well, you can of course find out right now If you remember the rest is history club because you can listen to our next episode which is all about the rise of William of Normandy But if you're not a member the rest is history club and you want to You can sign up at the rest is historycom and you know, Bob's your uncle. But Tom, for those people who don't want to do that, we will be back on Monday with a
他在其中使用了一个著名的短语，这个短语你花了很长时间研究，莎拉。那就是质问这些对其他国家效忠的美国人，在关键时刻，是否会把美国放在第一位。就是这个短语，对吧？
next thrilling chapter of this epic story. Bye bye. Bye bye. Here's that clip we mentioned earlier on. And gradually what you see in this period is mounting concern over what became called hyphenate Americans. This idea that foreign immigrant communities had divided allegiances. And so there are increasing demands for effectively loyalty tests. And Wilson gives a very famous speech
这部史诗般故事的下一个扣人心弦的章节。再见。再见。这就是我们刚才提到的那段音频。逐渐地，你会发现在这一时期，人们对被称为“连字符美国人”的群体日益感到担忧。这种观点认为，外国移民社团拥有分裂的效忠心。因此，人们越来越强烈地要求进行实质上的忠诚度测试。威尔逊发表了一场非常著名的演讲
in which he uses a famous phrase, and that's a phrase that you have spent a long time studying, Sarah. And that is to ask whether these Americans who have loyalties to other nations will, when it comes down to it, whether they will put America first. And that's the phrase, right?
他在演讲中使用了著名的词组，萨拉，这也是你花了很多时间研究的词组。那就是质问这些对其他国家效忠的美国人，在关键时刻，是否会把美国放在首位。这就是那个词组，对吧？
America first. It is a the phrase, right? America first. It is a phrase that was first popularized in this context in 1915, a year before Black Tom, in a speech that Wilson gave addressing these mounting concerns about hyphenate Americans, about whether they were real Americans or not. And the way that Wilson put it was he said, he demanded that immigrant communities stand up and state explicitly whether, he said, is it America first or is it not? And at that point, America first became an incredibly popular phrase. It basically dominates American political discourse for the next decade. Then it kind of subsided and then it has a resurgence around World
“美国优先”。这是一个短语，对吧？“美国优先”。这个词在1915年首次在这个语境下流行起来，也就是“黑汤”事件前的一年，当时威尔逊发表了一场演讲，回应了对“带连字符的美国人”日益增长的担忧，即他们到底是真正的美国人还是别的什么。威尔逊的表达方式是，他要求移民社团站出来明确表态，他说，究竟是不是“美国优先”？从那时起，“美国优先”成了一个极其流行的短语。在接下来的十年里，它基本上主导了美国的政治话语。然后它逐渐退潮，接着在世界……
War II when it was used to talk about whether America should enter the Second World War. And then it went into abeyance for a long time until it made a dramatic reappearance in the 21st century, which listeners will be familiar with. If you want to hear the full episode, listen to Journey Through Time wherever you get your podcasts. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
……第二次大战期间再次复苏，当时这个词被用来讨论美国是否应该参战。随后它沉寂了很长时间，直到在21世纪戏剧性地重现，听众对此应该不会陌生。如果你想收听完整单集，请在各大播客平台收听《时间之旅》。本集目前还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。